the CBS hit drama fire country normally
heats up the screen on Friday nights but
this week the hot Prime Time drama has a
special episode airing Sunday night
after the AFC Championship game right
here on channel 8. so keep your TV on
actress Diane Farr plays Cal Fire Chief
Sharon Leone joins us now to talk about
the fiery special episode nice to see
you thanks so much for joining us and oh
my gosh let's just jump right into it
there are so many complicated
relationships in this show about loss
and love and resentment and you are the
common thread with your relationship
with your husband Vince your son Bodie
and your spiraling Health what do you
like best about this show Diane oh
you're so sweet you got it all in there
uh what I like best I think is my son
and my husband on the show it's this
family drama where we get to like we'd
be really imperfect so that's so strange
that we only ever show relationships on
TV from that first crash to the kids
will they make it won't they make it
we're like 30 years deep and my writers
let us argue and fight and I think
Sharon's a little uh overbearing when it
comes to her son at times like she wants
him to really be okay and uh all
characters come down to the
relationships they have so ours are
really strong and volatile it's fun this
special episode is going to be the
biggest one yet from what I've read what
can you tell us about this episode on
Sunday night
mostly that it follows the biggest game
in the whole world and my whole cast is
freaking out when it gets to be on
afterwards and I don't even understand
what those letters mean but in the
episode itself it's a big sweeping epic
Vistas a plane goes down and people are
trapped inside of a valley and we have
convict firefighters which is an actual
program in California as part of a
rehabilitation system for prisoners
fighting right alongside Cal Fire
personnel and they all go into this
Valley and it's the people that don't
want to leave and the questions come up
of what do you really want to value is
it your house is it your money is it the
people that live in it or do you want to
live your life differently than you
imagine which always comes back to our
our main character and it seems like
there's a lot of relationship lessons
that are kind of being learned too
through the show and let's get though to
your health which is a really a running
theme through the show and you need a
new kidney and in the last episode there
were a lot of you had a big fundraiser
and bringing people together to find a
donor for your kidney and in the last
episode we're getting some clues about
who may be a match for you you're going
to have to make a decision and tell me
about that decision
could you imagine finding out that your
kid is a match if you need a kidney and
what that would cost you as a parent you
know that you would put your child's
life in jeopardy to to save your own
it's a Sophie's Choice that I don't
think anybody wants to make so they're
they're putting it up in front of us
that my son is going to be a match
but I I hope she doesn't take it it just
doesn't feel like the cycle of life but
um it's great that we bring the like
true life thing of chronic kidney
disease of live donors in there but the
relationship of how do you thank someone
for that how do you how do you live with
them in your life afterwards I I don't
know how much gratitude one person can
have so we'll see how that plays out
well anxious to find out for sure thank
you so much Diane Farr it was a pleasure
to meet you and we'll be anxious to see
this episode and all the ones to follow
take care
looks like it's going to be fiery for
sure you can watch the new episode of
fire country after the AFC Championship
this Sunday right here on channel 8.
it's the Bengals versus the Chiefs
kickoff is at 3 30. the new episode of
fire country will air right after right
around seven o'clock then stay tuned for
our Sports rap program special with
appearances from former and current
Raiders and former golden Knight Derek
England that's always a great show too
it's going to be a full hour and you
love that show the the fire fire country
country queer Fanatics we watch it every
week so it's I'm kind of wrapped up into
it could you tell I was a little bit
into talking to diet that'll be after
the AFC Championship game of the NFC
Championship Game the Eagles and the
49ers that'll be first on Sunday for
your your Championship weekend